- [Interviewer] All right, Amber.
- Hey.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back again.
- Hi, thank you for having me.
- [Interviewer] So you had
a rough ride this year.
You got beaten up not long ago.
- [Amber] Yeah, I did.
A few months ago. Yeah.
Things have changed a lot.
You know, I have a couple of friends
that are saying to me,
what's wrong with you?
You're not the same.
So I started thinking about that.
Like, what's wrong with me?
I'm not the same.
So then I had to start asking
that frightful question,
like, am I different
because of what happened?
Have I been different
since what happened to me?
And they're like, yeah, you are.
As matter of fact,
it is, about when that
shit happened to you.
Man, I went to the police station,
and I walked into the thing,
the beginning, the desk, I
used to call the desk cop,
totally acted like I was bothering him.
He was like, from the beginning,
when I said I'm here to make a report
because I was assaulted.
He was like, oh, here we go
with another one of these again,
like it was, everything was a problem.
And I was hurting physically
and mentally, you know?
And I was like, wow, I didn't
got behind the door yet
and I'm already being treated like crap.
So I was waiting.
I think I waited about an hour and a half,
waiting for someone to talk to me
just to at least take down what happened,
the memory I did have of it left.
An hour and a half, I went
back up there like, you know,
hey what's up?
Oh, you're still here?
All right, let me see if there's
someone who can help you.
I said, no, it's okay.
Have a great day.
I walked out, he said hey,
get your face looked at.
And I start crying.
That's what they want,
get that face looked at.
And at night sometimes, when I go sleep,
that's the only thing I keep hearing.
Get that face looked at.
Like, I'm not a study
in beauty or anything.
I'm not going to knock myself down,
but I'm not going to put myself up there,
like I'm, you know, the most
beautiful woman in the world.
- [Interviewer] You're beautiful.
But having the broken teeth and the scars,
it's got to make it tough.
- The scars, the teeth,
the fact that I used to be
able to get, I say any guy,
but I used to not have a
problem with catching a date.
Now I'm begging with the beggars.
I've had to go way low on my price.
I do all kinds of things
to try to hide my flaws.
Then now I'm just like this is what it is,
take it, yes or no, you know.
Take it if you want it. If not, thank you.
It's really hard because I'm feeling it.
It also makes people think
that you're a doormat.
That they can do anything to you
or that they can abuse you or assault you.
And I had someone tell me,
you think that guy fucked your face up?
I'll your face up.
And I'm like, how much work you do to it?
Like, it was like,
nine things I could find
that's wrong with it.
And that hurts.
However, a lot of people
had great comments,
and words of encouragement,
show awesome compassion.
And I just want them to
see that I'm not dead.
I'm still here,
but I'm broken, without a doubt.
However, woe is me, remember
I said that a long time ago?
I never signed up for this shit.
So sometimes I get my
dark moments and I'm like,
I never signed up for this.
I never asked for all these problems.
I never asked for
any of the things that
have happened to me.
I just want to look out for my sister.
I just want to take care of her.
Never knew that making that decision
was going to make my whole life suck.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your sister.
She's wonderful. She's a Republican.
She has a business.
She's the polar opposite of me.
Completely opposite thinking of me.
I love her so much.
And she hates me.
She's doesn't hate me
because she doesn't know me.
We weren't raised together.
She hates what I
represent, or the way I am.
So she turned Republican.
She is against drugs.
She's against people on welfare services.
I call her, you think
I'm a waste of space.
And she says, no you're
not, but I'll be this
as long as she has what she has.
Nice cars, you know,
she's the polar opposite.
She's just, she's awesome.
And, but damn, I didn't
think that, you know,
making that decision was
going to be so life changing.
So I hate that shit.
To turn my mom into my family,
to seek for help,
to do it right,
to make sure my sister
wasn't in that apartment
with no lights, no gas, no food.
I mean, maybe I think of it,
like maybe I could have went
to this entity or this service
or maybe this relative,
or maybe I could go to my
dad's side of the family
instead of my mom's. It's always what if?
I really tried to put my chin
up and, you know, take it on.
They say, what makes you,
like what makes you cry will
make you laugh, you know.
And I can laugh with my sister.
I love her so much.
It's okay.
Maybe one day she'll come down
here and you can meet her.
She's awesome person.
And I looked at her and I think of
all the things I could have
been, I should be, but,
and I still could be, but I don't want to.
I don't got it in me no more.
I don't want to go to school.
I don't want to be seen.
- [Interviewer] You
don't go to school now?
- Nothing. I'm doing nothing
but feeling sorry for myself.
And I know it's fresh.
It just happen.
But with everything going
on in the world right now,
it's not the time to really
be feeling sorry for yourself.
- [Interviewer] And you're still working?
I have to.
But I do, I did see yesterday,
I saw an awesome commercial
with one of the, I don't
know if I can say it,
Amazon dealer,
and I want to try to get a job
with them for the holidays.
I know there's massive hiring.
Try at least,
try something,
but no, I'm not working.
I mean, I'm still working,
not going to school.
- [Interviewer] You've
been working the streets
for how long?
- Ten years, hard, heavy. Ten years.
- [Interviewer] And looking back,
what do you think of that
decision that you made?
- To work on the streets?
To be out here doing this?
At first, it was the right thing to do.
It fed me, it did everything for me,
but I didn't know anything
about the business,
or I didn't have no pimp.
I have one friend to turn
me out when I was a kid.
And like I said, I'm
looking for my Richard Gere
and I'm Julia Roberts.
So I've always on the
fairytale side of it.
- [Interviewer] So do you
think girls are looking
for some guy to save them?
- A savior?
Yes, this called captain (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
That's a common thing.
- Yes. They might not
admit it but they are,
because who wants to be doing this
when they're like 70 years old
60 years old?
You want to find someone.
I want to find somebody
who's going to be like
my Richard Gere,
and it's going to make
all my problems go away
and just help me make everything easier.
- [Interviewer] And from
the girl's perspective,
is that a real relationship,
or is it just an arrangement
that provides security
and gives them what they need?
Or is it both?
- It could be both.
It could be all three.
(indistinct) arrangement.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. It's
always this blurred line.
- Right, it's all three.
Me, I'm getting to the point where,
I'll just like, I'll take anybody.
He could be old, he could be young,
could be girl.
- [Interviewer] You've
been in love before?
- A lot, yeah. Currently, I
thought I was in love right now.
I thought I was in love.
But I really don't know what love is.
The examples I've had,
have been poor examples.
I know what the definition of the word is.
I believe that I'm in love,
but at the end of the day,
love wouldn't do the
things that it does to me.
So I don't know. Maybe not.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like you love yourself?
- They sort of told me
that, like they said,
you can't let me until you love yourself.
And I'm like, what do you mean?
What is love yourself mean?
What does that mean?
- [Interviewer] To love
yourself means to be able to
accept all the good things
that life has to offer.
In a relationship, that
would mean to be able to
accept a partner who is
kind, supportive, patient,
someone who's fully
invested in helping you
to fulfill your dreams.
- That's like that Cinderella story.
- [Interviewer] Maybe from
the world you come from
it seems like a Cinderella thing.
- (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] It's almost
like love needs to be
this almost impossible
situation where both partners
believe they're lucky
to have the other person
in their lives at the same time.
I need to believe that I'm
lucky to have you in my life,
and you need to secretly
believe that you're lucky
that I'm in your life
and that has to co-exist.
So when that's out of balance,
one person gets bored and then,
yeah, it falls apart.
And it's a constantly changing dynamic
where one person, you know, gets older,
one person gets depressed,
- Right. No, I can't say,
I mean, I love myself.
I can say that.
I love myself enough to put on clothes.
I love myself enough to strive,
work on living every day.
That's the kind of love I have for myself.
I love myself enough to live,
and that'd be the best
way, or the best life.
But I think I love myself enough to live
because I wake up every morning,
like, ooh, thank you, Lord.
Thank you for waking me up.
Even if it's to deal
with the worst day ever.
Thank you.
'Cause my mom passed away in her sleep,
so I hold on dear waking up.
I think that's why I don't like
to go to sleep much, either.
You know, but hey, it's inevitable.
I don't know, things have changed.
I didn't want to, next time you saw me,
I'd be in a mental institution
or missing an arm or a leg
and not know what happened
in that gap of time.
You know, I just want to stay relevant
and stay, somebody out there cares
because I've seen the number, you know.
- [Interviewer] Is this your lowest point?
- Yep.
No. My lowest point was
when I lost my children.
So this is right around there.
They're fighting.
- [Interviewer] And
you have how many kids?
- I have four children.
- [Interviewer] And they're with who now?
- Not really sure.
I know that my oldest is with his dad
and the last three are
hopefully they're all together
in a foster home together or something.
'Cause I got twins.
Then a year later I had another baby,
and they were all taken by the
state and me and my issues,
I didn't, I messed my twins up.
This thing, my children,
my twins, visiting them,
I gave them an anxiety
condition where they worry
about if the parents they're
with is going to leave them.
So I've made a decision
with my last child, Jacob,
not to be a part of his life.
Not to put myself there
and then have to disappear,
not to put myself in a situation
where I pretend like I'm okay.
I do everything the tell
me to do, the classes,
everything that takes to
get your children back.
And then a year later I mess up
and they go to all different places
and have to experience
that separation anxiety
all over again.
So I try to ease their pain.
I believe, probably wrong,
but it's what I hold on to.
I believe that me not being
around and me not being in
is it's going to eliminate some
of that separation anxiety.
I'm all screwed up, I know. Sorry.
- [Interviewer] If you could
put your finger on one thing
that set your life down this path,
what would you say that was?
- The one thing, I don't know,
not knowing that you're
supposed to tell someone
when you're being touched
or bothered by an adult.
Because I took that sexual
abuse I got as a small child,
it stayed with me.
It just matured, you know.
I looked at Playboy magazines.
I was very curious about
sex, sexual things.
And I did a lot of secret things.
Like I would play with little
boys in the closets and stuff.
So like these all stemmed from
be being touched as a child.
- [Interviewer] It goes
both ways, doesn't it?
For some women, they
close off to sexuality
and for others, they
become more promiscuous.
- I was thinking about the other day,
I was talking to someone about it,
and I was saying how my
molester was my first love.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- I was in love with someone
at the age of four years old.
Had to be around that person,
cry when I couldn't be with them,
devastated When my mom stopped
sending me to the house
to be babysat.
Depressed because I lost my
first love in the first grade.
First started talking about running away
and hurting myself in first grade.
Because the one person that
played with me all the time,
that was my best friend,
she's my best friend,
was also the one hurting
me and touching me
and who I was in love with.
I think that's love.
Even at six years old,
when he wasn't around,
I cried and I was sad
and I mourned as a child.
- [Interviewer] That's heavy.
- I know.
My life gets heavier,
but I don't know.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think you struggle with most?
Is it anxiety, depression, anger?
- Depression.
Because everything makes me cry.
Everything's sad.
Can never see, well not can never,
I don't see the good stuff,
I've always noticed the sad stuff.
The dark gloomy stuff first, you know.
- [Interviewer] And does the shame, guilt,
from your situation with your
kids, does that get to you?
- Guilt, that guilt.
So there's depression
and there's the guilt.
The guilt, the mother's guilt is so huge.
I'm saying for me,
I don't know about any other parent,
any other mother out there,
but my mother's guilt is huge
because I have babies out there
and I don't know where they are.
I think about them
every day, all the time.
I don't have a clue.
I put them in harms way
by not getting them back.
So I pray at night that they
don't turn out to be like me.
Hopefully I broke the cycle in my family.
Because I'm doing what mom did.
She's doing what her parents did.
I'm hoping with them being
away, I broke the cycle.
That they won't experience my lifestyle.
But then other times, I'm just like,
what if they call out for me at night?
What if they call out for me at night?
What if someone's hurting them?
Then you hear all these horror stories
about the Department of
Child and Family Services,
how they're just awful.
And the guilt.
So I'm not going to feel anything.
I'm going to go out and go score.
For at least this hour,
I'm not going to be thinking about them.
- [Interviewer] It makes you feel.
- I don't feel.
- [Interviewer] You don't feel?
- Yeah, I feel but it doesn't exist.
- [Interviewer] It all disappears.
- Oh, there's no feeling. Nothing.
These scars or children. I'm, just high.
- [Interviewer] It's all okay.
- It's all okay.
I was like, I'm cheating,
I'm taking the easy way out.
That's when I get depressed.
It's not just the drugs.
It's real, you know,
the depression is real.
It's real because
sometimes it gets so dark
that I don't want to wake up.
I don't want to wake up.
Fuck it.
You know, let's do it now. I'm done.
But I'm not going to do it myself.
I'm not gonna do it myself.
But luckily, I'm not going to do it myself
because I think that my religion
has something to do
with that. A large part.
- [Amber] And so a lot of
these guys they're pimping
but they're doing, they're
what they call a boyfriend.
They're the boyfriend, you know.
The girls don't know that
they're being pimped.
They really think that
that's their boyfriend
and this is just what
he's allowed her to do.
But in actuality, he's pimping,
his whole conversation
when she's not around
is about pimping and how he's pimping her
and stuff like that.
Or his friends know, or, you
know, that's the worst part.
The kind that play you like
you're their girlfriend.
And you fall all in love with them,
and it turns out that
they are pimping you.
Or accepting your money.
- [Interviewer] Managing your money.
Yeah. Managing my money
accepting my money,
like I owe you this.
- [Interviewer] It's interesting
how a lot of the older girls have told me
that when they finally got
out, got away from their pimp,
they asked them if they
kept any of the money,
or they saved any money.
And the answer is always no.
Oh no.
Like when they, like, if
they separate from him?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, somehow.
- You're lucky if you get
the clothes on your back.
- [Interviewer] That's what I'm saying.
- It's just a bad situation.
- [Interviewer] You've
been doing this for awhile.
Do you know anyone who's done
this and gotten out unscathed?
They saved money and bought a house?
Something like that?
They actually saved money, were set.
- Oh no, not even.
Because you literally give
all your money to this person
- [Interviewer] But even without a pimp.
- No. For instance, me, I
was like a perfect example.
If I left, I would be
battered and bruised.
Inside and outside.
No one gets out of here. Not even the guy.
- [Interviewer] The street
life is addicting, isn't it?
- Oh, it's very addicting.
It's like a drug.
You want it, you desire it,
and your brain tells you you need it
just like drugs, just like a drug.
- [Interviewer] So it seems
the sexual abuse that happens
in childhood leads to drug
use, which leads to sex work
which leads to losing your children
and it leads to depression
and just an endless chain of destruction.
If that sexual abuse had never occurred,
the trajectory of your life
would have been very different.
- If that trauma never occurred,
a lot would be different.
A lot would be different.
That one thing, trauma can occur,
but if you fix it with,
you know, with help
psychiatric help or, you know,
or awareness of the parent
knowing what's going on,
it's fixable, if you fix it, they can,
or she can, get through it,
live, survive.
So she survived that trauma.
But if you don't fix it,
then that trauma sits there
and the trauma goes on top
of there, on top of that.
And you end up having children
and whenever they are
and on the streets still.
10 years later
- [Interviewer] There's a lot of things
about this lifestyle that are problematic.
But one of the things
that really gets to me,
after hearing all these
stories, is how there's no one
in your life who cares for
you, who truly cares for you.
I mean, from the tricks to the pimps
to the other girls on the
street to the cops, like nobody.
Everyone's on the take,
everyone's got their own best interests.
And you're just something
to be used and thrown away.
And that must be a really
lonely way to go through life.
- Yeah, that's probably
one of the worst ways
to go through life, not mattering.
If you know that, then
you're a little bit better
than the person who has no clue,
who's still living in a fog
that these people care
about them, but like
they're called throwaways.
That's what I try to remind people.
- [Interviewer] They just
want your money or your body.
- They're users.
They want this, they want that.
- [Interviewer] They use you up.
- Definitely. They use you up.
So you kill yourself,
or end up in some jail
forever or something.
- [Interviewer] We talked last week
about you getting depressed sometimes.
Do you ever get suicidal?
- Yeah, I have gotten suicidal
several times, you know,
but I know religion, and in my religion
it's the biggest no-no,
and thankfully that's the one
thing that's kept me alive
because when I'm in my darkest moment,
you cannot tell me at that time
that any of these are gonna be better.
It's the end of the world for me.
And when it's the end of the world for me,
well, let me just go ahead
and just do what I need to do.
But my religion has kept
me alive because I know
that it's like, it's a big no-no.
I can't do it.
- [Interviewer] I'll drive
down Figueroa some nights,
and I'll just, I want to rent a school bus
and pick up all the girls and save them.
- And not only are they saveable,
some of them don't want to be saved.
Some of them, this is what they believe,
or they know that this is their calling.
- [Interviewer] I think, you know,
tell me if this makes sense to you.
It's almost like, I mean,
very often there are stories
of sexual abuse in childhood
and we all try to recreate
those childhood relationships
in one way or another,
but that's what we all do.
The significant relationships
of our childhood
we tend to recreate as adults.
And it's the only thing that
we'll accept as an adult.
Some form of that, not
better, not different.
And this life is a very good replacement
for that abuse that a lot of
the girls had as children.
Having guys that will just do
whatever they want with you
disrespect you and throw you away.
- And you become used to that.
And that becomes your normal.
And you don't understand,
you don't recognize--
- [Interviewer] Even if
something better came along,
you'd find some way to reject it.
And you only want that.
And this lifestyle supplies that
and anything else is of no interest.
- Right. You don't recognize
the good in anything
because you're just used to--
- [Interviewer] If
something good came along,
you'd reject it.
- I'd miss him. I would miss him,
because I think he's
some of the lame loser.
Some lame person.
Well, I mean--
- [Interviewer] You wouldn't trust him.
- If Richard Gere came into my
life, I wouldn't believe it,
because why me?
Like, how did I get chosen?
- [Interviewer] But even
if somehow he broke through
and you guys got into a
relationship together.
- I'd ruin the relationship.
- [Interviewer] You'd
ruin the relationship.
- Because that's not my
normal. I'm not used to that.
I can't appreciate this glass of wine.
There's no appreciation for it.
- [Interviewer] I'm glad you said that.
What would you say to a young girl,
a young woman, who's
considering this career?
- Well, considering this lifestyle is a,
you got to see everything.
The good and the bad, like,
of course you get money
but can you imagine sleeping
with, say, eight guys a day,
365 days a year, do that math.
And you're literally putting
your body through that trauma.
You're going to be traumatizing yourself.
You get to a point where
it becomes so addictive
it's like, you have to
go to like an AA meeting,
a fellowship, a AA meeting,
to figure out how to
live with that craving,
that desire, that allergy.
And I would just suggest
that you just don't do it.
Don't do it, like there's
other ways to make money.
And especially right now with technology
and things going the way they are
you can make better money faster
with less risk because there's risk.
You're at risk your life.
You're going to risk your sanity.
You're going to risk your
family. Everything's is so risky.
Imagine like, okay, today I'm safe.
I have a beautiful face.
I'm normal.
And then two hours later,
I'm beat to a pulp.
That's the risk you take.
And then you think that
this person, your boyfriend,
or your man, or your,
your people, your folks
you think that they care about you
and that they'll patch you
up, they'll mend you up.
They might just give you a band-aid
and just send you right back out there.
Or they might just throw you away.
You're no good to them.
Because everyone's not made to be rich.
Everyone's not supposed to be rich
but I would rather have my
mental okay and be poor,
or be without the money
that I'm getting now.
- [Interviewer] I have a
lot of very wealthy friends
and they're more miserable than a lot
of the people I interview
in Appalachia recently,
or in South Central. Or on skid row.
- Happiness is key.
But to the young ladies or the young man
that are thinking about
getting into this profession
because they can get it
like that, or, you know
they'll have nice things,
those things fade.
So do looks, so do beauty.
Skin fades, it sags, just don't do it.
I'm not really sure how to
tell someone not to do it
because I was never told how not to do it.
I could just share my experiences
and my life experiences
and what I go through every day
and what I'm going through now as a guide.
So this is what can happen.
If you follow this road,
this is what's going to happen.
You're going to get hurt.
You're going to, it's just
numbers mathematically.
You're just, it has to happen.
- [Interviewer] All right, Amber,
thank you so much for
talking with me again.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- [Interviewer] This was great.
- Thank you.